Yellow,
so some of you may have heard about the
Google memo that has been circulating
virally around the Internet for the last
couple of days that was written by James
Demore who was fired for it last night
and a colleague of his reached out to me
and put us together and so I'm going to
talk to James today about exactly what
happened and why and perhaps what should
be done about it.
So I'll.
So that's what we're going to do.
The interview I had with him,
which finished at about 3:00 on Tuesday,
August eighth.
Follows immediately after this
introduction.
Hi everybody.
I'm speaking today with James Demore and
an unidentified google employee who
wishes to remain anonymous.
Reasons that I think are obvious.
And James last week put his hand in a
blender by circulating an internal memo
that I would say has become somewhat
infamous.
So James,
let's start with,
let's start with a bit of discussion
about you tell us who you are,
about your background and about what you
were doing at Google.
Alright.
Yeah.
So I was actually just,
you know,
I really interested in science and
psychology and stuff and then I really
liked puzzles and that's how I got into
Google.
Actually I did one of their coding
competitions,
they just recruited me out of that.
And so I Google,
I was mostly working on search and image
and video searches.
So what's.
Tell us about your educational
background a bit.
Alright.
Yeah.
So I just did a random science and math
and undergrad and I ended up with a
degree.
I didn't really know what I was gonna
do.
So I started doing research at Mit and
then uh,
I went to a systems biology at Harvard.
I initially wanted to work with Martin
Nowak.
He's really great in evolution and Game
Theory.
But uh,
then I started working on other things.
So tell us a bit of road systems
biology.
What,
what is that exactly?
What kind of research were you doing?
Alright.
Yeah.
So systems biology has many different
meanings but it's generally just
mathematical biology and uh,
I guess seeing biological systems as a
whole rather than just individual
molecules.
And so I,
I liked looking at populations and so my
interest in evolution.
So why did that make you a viable
candidate at Google?
It's eight.
Uh,
I think they just saw a smart guy that
could code.
Now you've been there three years,
is that correct?
But also as an intern before that?
Yeah.
So about four years total.
And so how would you say you've
performed as an employee and Google and
people being happy with you or have you
been here?
No,
I,
I got promoted twice.
My last review was a,
the highest possible to per which is the
top two percentile.
So it definitely wasn't based on
performance if they fire me.
Have you enjoyed working at Google as it
being a good experience?
Yeah,
I love Google.
That's horrible part.
Like I've always been the biggest Google
fanboy,
all like I've never had an iphone.
I've always tried to convince my friends
to use android and all of these
different things.
And yeah,
I mean this is just puts a sour taste in
my mouth.
Okay.
So,
so you've got a good educational
background.
You were interested in things that
Google would be interested in.
Your good coder,
you've worked with him for a number of
years,
have done an excellent job and you're
pretty pro google.
That's basically the background.
Okay.
Now last week you wrote a memo which has
attracted a tremendous amount of
attention and in that memo you,
you made a number of claims and the
claims were,
and please correct me if I've got this,
if I'm not summarizing this property,
you were attempting to describe reasons
why there might be a lack of gender
parody might exist within Google,
for example,
and with an NGO,
engineering or broadly,
but also in occupations more broadly.
And you,
um,
you laid out a very elaborated document
and I reviewed it and as far as I can
tell,
your opinions are well supported by the
relevant psychological science.
And I think what I'll do in the
description of this video when I link it
is putting the references so then people
can decide for themselves.
I want to put up a webpage about gender
differences in general,
but I'll try to hit the highlights for
this particular document.
So why did you do this?
Yeah,
so about a month and a half ago I went
to one of our diversity summits,
all of it on recorded and super secret
and they told me a lot of things that I
thought just were not right.
Okay.
What do you mean unrecorded and super
secret?
Well,
I mean they were telling us about a lot
of these potentially illegal practices
that they've been doing to try to
increase diversity and
what kinds of practices?
Uh,
well basically treating people
differently based on what their race or
gender are.
Yeah.
Basically.
I see.
I'm so,
and it was ultra secret and unrecorded
and in what manner?
Uh,
yeah.
So I,
most meetings I Google,
I recorded anyone at Google watch it.
We're trying to be really open about
everything except for this now.
They don't want any paper trail for any
of these things.
Well,
okay.
Why?
Because I think it's illegal and I mean
as some of the internal polls showed,
there were a large percent of people
that agreed with me on the document and
so if everyone got to see this stuff
then they would really bring up some
criticism,
a large number of people in Google and a
very large number of well-informed
biological scientists we might also add.
So I was quite struck by your document
given that.
No,
it would have been at a decent document
for a well informed psychologists
research psychologist to.
Right.
But it was somewhat of an outsider,
but you've got the,
you got the highlights.
Accurate as far as I'm concerned.
So.
Okay.
So you went to this diversity meeting
and you weren't happy with the sorts of
things that you were being told and with
the practices are,
is that both correct?
Yeah.
And what we're being told.
Well,
so that,
I mean there's a lot of ways in which
they pressure people to increase the
diversity of their team.
And now there's no way to do that
besides actually choosing someone based
on their race or gender.
Right?
Mean,
precisely.
Uh,
I am more women or underrepresented
racial minorities.
Can I jump in?
Yeah,
yeah.
I,
I would hesitate to say that that's 100
percent true.
One hundred percent right.
So the organization that I'm in,
I have not personally seen anything that
I would deem crossed the line,
you know,
I personally believe that there are a
good amount of synergies to be found if
you can combine,
you know,
slightly different ideologies into a
room and that is the,
the thesis that some groups are working
towards.
Um,
obviously there's going to be a
distribution of how people follow the
rules.
Um,
and you know,
it's unfortunate to hear that it's,
you know,
it could be that some people fall to the
wrong side of that distribution,
but that certainly wouldn't,
it would not apply to everybody.
Certainly.
It certainly also distressing to hear
that there is acceptance of the idea
that diversity can be mapped onto race
and gender,
especially with regards to performance
because there's no evidence for that
whatsoever.
So.
Okay,
so you went to this meeting and then you
decided to write this document and um,
how long had you been working on it
before he released it?
Yeah,
so I was doing it throughout my free
time.
I,
and I just wanted to clarify my thoughts
on this and I really just want it to be
proven wrong because,
you know,
if what I was saying was right then
something bad is happening and so about
a month ago I submitted it to feed back
to that program and you know,
I saw that people looked at it but no
one actually said anything.
And what did you submit?
Uh,
I mean I basically said what I said in
the,
in the document and then I linked to the
document itself and so I actually
published this about a month ago
and
it was only after it got viral and then
we to the news that Google started
carrying,
how did it go viral and how was it
leaked?
Yeah.
So I,
there is a group at Google called
skeptics and so I was like,
okay,
maybe they'll be able to prove me wrong
in some way.
Like they're skeptical about things,
right.
I wasn't naive I guess,
and so I sent them a message like,
okay,
what do you think about this?
Is Google in some sort of echo chamber
or I'm crying and echo chamber
and,
and then it just exploded after that.
And you know,
our internal.
Yeah.
It was just spread throughout all
google.
Do you and do you know,
was it the,
was it the skeptic's group that started
to spread it around?
Yeah.
And then
there were a lot of upper management
that uh,
you know,
specifically called it out and started
saying how harmful it is and how is
unacceptable.
This sort of viewpoint is not allowed at
Google.
Yeah.
What sort of viewpoint?
Exactly the idea that there are
differences between men and women that
actually might play a role in,
in,
in the,
in the corporate world.
That's an opinion that's not acceptable.
Yeah,
it seems a,
well,
understandably it is just these issues
are tricky morally and politically,
but thing that was disturbing to me
about watching the response to you is
that as far as I can tell,
there isn't anything that you said in
that paper.
First of all that is in fact biased in
the manner that should open you up to
the sorts of charges that have been
opened up against you or that violates
the scientific literature as it
currently stands.
So both of those are rather distressing.
Yeah,
and there's a lot of misrepresentation
by upper management just to silence me I
think.
Yes.
And why is that?
You think like why?
Why is it the Google couldn't have
actually you think that Google couldn't
have come out and have an intelligent
discussion about this instead of.
Well first of all,
releasing like Danny,
I read Danielle Brown's response to you,
which I thought was absolutely
appalling.
It was formed and the following and then
they fired you,
which seems to be like really bad pr
move,
but more importantly doesn't actually
deal with the issues at hand.
You know,
they're basically saying something like,
well,
what was the rationale for firing you?
Exactly what was the excuse that was
given?
So the official case was that I was
perpetuating gender stereotypes
that you were perpetuating gender
stereotypes?
Yeah.
And did they say anything else about
your performance or about anything else
that you'd done?
No,
it was,
that was the only reason.
And who,
who,
who fired you?
Technically?
Uh,
it was my hr representative and my
director.
Okay.
And do you end,
do you have any idea on who's ordered
they were acting or if this was
something that they conjured up
themselves or.
I,
I'm sure I probably went from higher up
than that because I missed a huge pr
move.
So they would need approval from higher
ups.
Right.
And I think the CEO,
the CEO actually made some comments
about the issue today,
which I'll probably cut into this video
as we,
as I edited.
So yeah.
Okay.
Alright.
So the first question is how are you
doing?
I'm doing okay.
I there's a lot of messages that I'm
trying to sort through and just trying
to figure out what I should do now,
but
yeah,
you've been given some interesting job
offers as far as I know.
Yeah,
I've gotten a surprising amount as part.
Yeah.
Well,
I suspect,
I'm sorry,
I'm virtually certain that you have a
majority viewpoint.
It's just the people who hold the
alternative perspective,
which are the radical social
constructionist types,
who insists that everything is a
consequence of socialization.
There are a little bit more organized
politically,
but they're clearly wrong.
Scientifically they're wrong factually
the wrong ethically for that.
So.
So you,
you probably have more support than you
think and it'll be very interesting to
see how that turns out.
So,
so what do you think about having
written this mean now?
Your life is going to be turned upside
down and for quite a while I suspect.
I mean,
so you put yourself out on the line
doing this,
so what do you think about that?
It definitely sucks,
but at least I was proven right know
when.
What do you mean by proven right?
Oh,
just the whole
culture just tries to silence.
I needed a dissenting view
and then we really need some more
objective way of looking at these.
Yeah,
well I felt the same way with the
University of Toronto decided to,
you know,
an attempt to shut me down after I need
my videos.
I thought,
well that just proves my point because I
mean I made the videos saying,
well I don't like the climate that's
developing it.
It's making it very difficult to have
conversations about certain things.
And your example is even more egregious
I think because at least objected to a
piece of legislation that in principle
would have been a benefit to an
identifiable group,
but say the transgender group,
I don't believe it is of any benefit to
them,
but you could make a case that it was,
but you.
All you did as far as I can tell is
review the modern personality literature
and the literature on individual
differences relating to men and women
and other groups.
And there's actually not very much your
opinion in your piece at all.
So what that means is that it is not
possible to actually have a discussion
about the scientific literature on these
issues without putting yourself at risk
and that's a hell of a thing for an
engineer because being engineers and
rely on the facts as far as I can tell.
And one of the things I like about
engineers is that they tend to stick
fairly closely to the facts that they're
not a very political group.
You know,
generally speaking,
they're much more practical.
I don't know how they can expect a
silence.
So many engineers then intelligent
people and just
deny science.
Like it's like
this.
Yeah.
Well the question too is what are your
supporters within Google going to do?
Because you know,
I would say you're a great warning man,
because you,
you showed what happened,
you showed exactly what happens if you
have enough,
I don't know what you'd call it,
curiosity and courage I suppose,
but,
but mostly curiosity to lay out what you
think for discussion.
You opened this conversation.
You said that you weren't jumping up and
down and insisting you were right.
You were trying to lay out what you
understood from doing a fair bit of
reading and,
and make the case that the,
these facts,
the facts about the differences between
men and women and employment choice and
payment and all that aren't being
discussed and they're not being
discussed.
I mean we know for example,
and I'll put this citation down in the
description,
has been very difficult for the Swedes,
for example,
to flatten out the gender distribution
for engineers in Sweden and in and in
and in the Scandinavian countries in
general,
despite their advanced social
engineering,
let's call it.
And they also can get male nurses,
you know,
I think it's four out of five nurses in
Scandinavia,
if I remember correctly,
are female and the reverse number are
our engineers are male and you know,
that seems to be associated with this
quite well founded.
Um,
scientific observation that women tilt
towards interest in people and men tilt
towards interest in things and that
that's associated with testosterone
exposure in utero.
This is science.
Anybody beating an ideological trump
because most of the people I would say
that most of the people who are
publishing this would have been even
happier.
How did turned out the other way,
you know,
the findings actually run contrary to
their biases because academia is
generally full of people whose biases
are less and now and then you know,
scientific findings emerged to dispute
on India.
Logical proposition not certainly the
case with role of biology versus society
in establishing gender differences.
So the science is very credible.
It doesn't mean it's completely beyond
dispute,
but that's not the point either because
your survey was actually pretty decent
survey of the current state of affairs
with regards to individual differences.
That doesn't mean it's right.
So,
okay,
so what,
what are your,
what does your family think about all
this?
Yeah,
they definitely support me,
but they don't really know what I should
do from here.
They don't want me to just go to a ton
of news corporations and do all these
interviews and stuff and because they
just want to twist whatever I say
towards their agenda to.
It's not really clear what I should be
doing.
Yeah,
well,
there's certainly no shortage of people
that want to talk to you.
I mean,
I'd been contacted by four or five
journalists who would like to speak with
you.
We can talk about that afterwards.
I can let you know who they are,
but um,
yeah.
Well you've got a,
you've got a conundrum on your hands.
No,
I mean you're,
you're a,
you're a very straightforward person and
you're obviously not grinding any acts,
at least not in any order is waiting.
So my suspicions are that talking to the
right people could be substantial use to
you,
but I guess it also depends on what it
is that you want me.
And that's something we can talk about
now you've,
you've,
you've rattled up the cages have a fair
number of people and a fairly large
organization,
interestingly enough just on the heels
of Google and youtube.
So the announcement about the new free
speech restrictions on,
on Youtube,
you know,
and their incorporation of Ngo who's
into that sensor set process.
So it's been quite a week for Google I
would say.
So you've opened up this can of worms,
what is it that,
so imagine if you're looking six months
down the road and say,
and things happened that were good
because of what you did,
what is it that you would like to have
happen
at the very least I want,
because I do still care about google.
I want some conversation to be had and
for the ideologues to not just have
their way,
but yeah,
I still don't have a clear vision on how
exactly this will happen.
How,
how this can spread farther than just
google
well farther than just google.
Yeah.
You know,
um,
I mean I would say my experiences with
the premise is that the first thing that
happens that will happen is that you'll
get jumped on by people who call you the
sorts of epithets that would be
appropriate if you were a bad guy and
you should just shut up and go away.
Okay.
That's already happened.
But I think you're going to get through
that real quick because I went through
your,
um,
your writings which are not as screened
by the way on are certainly not anti
diversity street.
I went to the writing center and I can't
see anything there that identifies you
as the sort of person that can be easily
and permanently tarred with a hateful
epithets.
But you know,
it's logical for the public,
let's say,
including the media to jump on someone
like you when they blow a whistle.
Because the first thing that you might
presume if someone's causing trouble is
that there's something wrong with them.
So then you have to sort of beat them
awhile with the idea that there's
something wrong with them to see what
happens.
And so the first thing is you have to
withstand that,
but there don't seem to be any smoking
pistols into your background.
So for example,
you were in an ideal Google employee,
well that protects you a lot and you
don't have a history of this,
of any sort of trouble making and you
have a solid educational background and
you're clearly a reasonable person.
And so the first thing is just to steel
yourself to get through that.
And then what happened,
I think if you do talk to media
organizations and especially if you talk
to them the way that you're talking to
me,
which is extraordinarily calm and
composed,
then you're going to reveal yourself
even more as a reasonable person and the
press overall will start to shift behind
you.
And I think the reason for that is one
thing you got to remember about the
press is that when push comes to shove,
they're actually rather in favor of free
speech
giving.
Without it they would be dead.
So I don't think like,
I don't think that you have to worry
about being exploited and twisted by
media sources.
I actually think that it might be to
your advantage to talk to people,
you know,
you can figure out who those people are,
but you're just not the kind of person
that can be easily transformed into a
villain.
And the more that you can demonstrate
that,
the better might be,
you know,
for the cause that you're engaged in,
but also for yourself.
So what?
So like how are you feeling about this
emotionally?
You must be in a bit of a state of
shock.
Thanks.
It's been a stressful week for sure.
I'm not feeling too negative about it.
Yeah,
I.
It hasn't fully hit me,
I don't think.
Yeah.
Well it will because God only knows
what's gonna happen to you over the next
few weeks.
Right?
It's going to be a real rollercoaster.
And the other thing that you might
consider is that it's possible that this
will turn out extraordinarily positive
for you.
You know,
there's gonna be it's gonna be a rough
ride,
but
to the degree that you are accurate in
your observations,
then you know it's not that easy to.
It's not that easy for the opponents of
truth to have a battle with truth.
It's not easy to have a battle that you
tended to lose.
So can I just go over some of the things
that you sent so that we can discuss it.
So I'm going to take a look here.
So you started with a pretty good solid
statement.
I would say Google's political bias has
equated the freedom from offense with
psychological safety,
but shaming into silence is the
antithesis of psychological safety.
Well,
that seems even more relevant now in
your situation.
The science is created ideological echo
chamber where some ideas are too sacred
to be honestly discuss.
Well,
we can check that one off too,
right?
It certainly seems to indicate that was
the case.
The lack of discussion discussion
fosters the most extreme and
authoritarians elements of this
ideology.
Some of the extreme,
the extreme is all disparities in
representation or do new oppression.
That's a good one,
right?
That's a univariate hypothesis.
It's very,
very simple minded.
And then the authoritarian element,
you defined as the idea we should
discriminate correct for this
oppression.
Great.
And then you make a claim just
difference in distributions of traits
between men and women May in part
explain why we don't have 50 percent
representation of women in tech and
leadership discrimination to reach equal
representation is unfair.
Divisive and bad for business.
Okay,
so that's your thesis and then you go
along and try to justify it.
So the first thing you do is talk about
left wing versus right wing biases,
and I should point out that you don't
concentrate on the left biases or on the
right biases.
You're completely even handed with
regards to laying out the pros and cons.
So the lack of compassion for the week.
Disparities are due to injustices.
Humans are inherently cooperative
changes,
good slash unstable,
open an idealistic,
fair enough man,
you're dead on with regards to the
relevant psychological literature.
Where are we seeing that political
correctness is motivated by
agreeableness and that liberalism is
fundamentally predicted by openness and
the right biases.
Respect for authority,
disparities are natural.
Adjust humans are inherently
competitive.
Changes,
dangerous,
stable.
That would be high conscientiousness,
low openness and they're closed rather
than open and pragmatic rather than
idealist.
Yeah.
Well,
I don't think any reasonable person
could read that column and say that you
were coming down hard on the side of
either part of the political spectrum.
Dr Peterson.
Can I jump in with a question?
It appears from my interactions with
many people that they are projecting
words that were not written onto the
paper and would you be able to elaborate
on the schemas that people develop and
how they classify information in their
minds because this is very much how
stereotypes form I would think,
um,
is by kind of just grouping a bunch of
disparate but semi related people or
things together and then projecting an
idea that may or may not pertain to
that.
Yeah.
Well,
it's a,
it's a low resolution thought issue.
I mean,
what,
what's happened to James is that he,
you know,
he,
he put up his hand and said,
wait a second,
I don't agree with the diversity
ideology.
And he was immediately declassified
essentially as a misogynist and bigot.
And that's the simplest thing to do,
right?
Because misogynists and bigots,
we'll hold viewpoints that are anti
female and racist.
And so it's a lot easier just to paint
someone with a broad brush,
especially if they're violating the
tenants of your implicit temperament,
let's say.
Then it is to dive into the details were
real thought occurs.
And I think one of the sins that James
committed was that he actually dared to
make this about details rather than
about vague hand waving ideology that's
very annoying to people who don't want
to think because in order to analyze his
claims,
you'd have to go through,
well let's say 20 or 30 scientific
papers and actually understand what they
mean.
And that's very annoying,
especially if you're pursuing a given
agenda.
So.
Okay.
So then you say neither side is 100
percent correct.
And both viewpoints are necessary for a
functioning society or in this case
company.
Yeah,
well I think the data is solid there
too.
I mean our research has indicated that
open people who are primarily liberal
start companies and the more closed
people,
the conservatives,
the traditionalist are good at running
them.
They're better at being managers and
administrators that's associated with
high conscientious.
So you've got it right there.
A company too far to the right,
maybe too slow to react over a higher
hierarchical and uninteresting and
accompany too far to the left will
overdressed,
diversify its interests already trusts
it's employees and competitors and
change perhaps to rapidly.
Yeah,
great,
fine,
perfect.
Nicely balanced as far as I can tell,
only facts and reasons can shed light on
these biases,
but when it comes to diversity and
inclusion,
Google's left bias is created a
politically correct monoculture that
maintains its hold by shaming descenders
into silence.
Well,
that certainly seems to be the case this
time as removes any checks against
encroaching extremist and authoritarian
policies,
right?
Like Google,
we're regularly told that implicit
unconscious and explicit biases are
holding women back in tech and
leadership.
Of course,
men and women experienced bias in the
workplace differently.
We should be cognizant of that,
but it's far from the whole story on
average men and women biologically
different.
In many ways.
These aren't just socially constructed
because they're universal across
cultures.
Clear biological causes links to
prenatal testosterone.
Biological males castrate them at birth
and raised.
His females often still identify and act
like males.
The underlying traits are highly
heritable and they're exactly what we
would predict from an evolutionary
psychology perspective.
No,
I'm not saying that all men differ from
women in the following ways or that
these differences are just,
and then you put it into nice chart
indicating that the amount of overlap
between men and women per trade is
greater than the amount of difference.
Right,
and so you state that directly.
That's.
That's perfect.
That's a very good way of defending your
thesis and also of not overstating the
case.
Then you do a nice job of of also
graphically indicating what happens if
the distribution is ignored and people
are just treated as if they're a unit
polar representatives of a given group,
which is kind of what the what the
people who are predicating the push for
diversity on gender and race are
assuming.
Right.
Which is.
Which is really so funny because it's
really a biologically essentialist
argument.
Much,
much greater than than than the argument
that you're making,
which is that men and women and the
members of different races are so
different that in order for a full
diversity of viewpoint to be achieved,
you have to pull in people by race and
gender which which,
which implicitly states that the
differences are so great that the
distributions don't overlap.
You couldn't make them more racist and
misogynist statement than that and it's,
and it's also technically wrong because
men and women are more alike than they
are different.
Maybe if you summed up all the
differences,
you could absolutely differentiate
between,
you know,
in all likelihood you could,
but some of those differences are
clinically irrelevant to the workplace.
Okay.
Then you go through the personality
difference literature and you're.
You're exactly right on that.
I see that the CEO took you to task for
using the word neuroticism.
However,
that is the technical term in the
personality literature and there are
historical reasons for that.
I'm a better word,
might be negative emotion,
but it's clearly the case that women are
higher in negative emotion than men,
and that means that they are on average,
less tolerant of uncertainty and stress.
They suffer more psychologically for for
the equivalent levels of uncertainty and
stress,
and that is also why cross culturally
women have more depressive disorders and
anxiety disorders and the research on
that is rock solid rock solid men have
their own problems,
right?
They're more likely to be antisocial,
they're much more likely to be in
prison,
they're more likely to have learning
disabilities.
So it's stating that there are
differences in the rates of certain
kinds of psychopathology.
It doesn't put any either gender into a
position of relative inferiority.
So,
and then you quote research that
suggests that greater nation level,
gender equality leads to psychological
dissimilarity,
dissimilarity and men and women's
personality traits.
Absolutely.
That's what the Scandinavian studies
indicate.
There's been a number of them and
they're very large studies,
so you've got that right.
What?
What does what the researchers
demonstrated was that as Ka Ka,
Ka,
as
countries move to flatten out the socio
economic playing field and remove
discrimination,
the differences between men and women
are many of the differences between men
and women maximize instead of minimize
it and in Scandinavia you really see
maximization of the difference in men
and women with regards to interest in
people versus interest in.
Thanks.
A major,
major issue.
Men's higher drive for status.
Yeah.
Well we know that women are hyper
agamous and that they choose men on the
basis of their socioeconomic status,
right?
Well documented cross culturally and
also just rational because women have to
make themselves dependent when they are
pregnant and when they have infants,
so that makes perfect sense for them to
seek out the most competent person they
can manage,
the most common and generous person they
can manage in order to help them bear
the burden.
So,
so not no,
no dispute there at least know you're
not
diverting from the central tenants of
evolutionary psychology and biology.
People will disseminate those findings,
but you're not conjuring this out of
thin air.
There's a nice in scientific literature
behind you,
so,
and you know,
it's also very interesting to look at
the US labor stats on gender differences
in occupations,
you know,
because it's so funny to watch the
radical feminists only go after the high
status occupations.
It's like 100 percent of brick layers
are net.
We don't hear that being being a
complaint about.
And of course men occupied most of the
outside jobs,
they move more and they will do more of
the dangerous jobs as well.
Um,
so,
so these are all factors that are,
are relevant but completely undiscussed
as far as I can tell by this sort of
ideological types that have been going
after you.
So women are on average,
more cooperative.
Yeah.
Especially with members of their
ingroup.
Whether they're more cooperative with
members of their outgroup is a different
story,
right?
Because agreeable people are in group
oriented and very hard on outgroup
members,
which I think is partly why the pc types
are so hard on their enemies because you
guard the nest predators,
predators on infants essentially.
Something like that.
Women on average are more prone to
anxiety.
Yes.
That's true.
A women on average look for more work
life balance.
That seems to be the case.
I don't know if the literature on that
is tight,
you know,
but it's certainly the case that law
firms,
for example,
have a hell of a time keeping their
women in,
in partnership positions because most of
them don't want to work the 60 hour work
week,
60 to 80 hour work weeks that are
necessary to performance at that
extremely high level.
So Dr Peterson for,
for anybody who might be new listening
in,
you mentioned that a lot of women might
not be
interested in working 60 to 80 hour work
week.
Do you think it would make sense to
expand upon that just a little bit?
Um,
I know you talked through hyper to me,
but you've also mentioned the thing
about why would anybody want to do that
no matter what your gender is.
We got to get the mystery right here.
The mystery isn't why there are a bunch
of people who are low status because
almost everyone's low status
comparatively speaking,
right?
Men and women alike.
It's a small minority of people who were
high status on any dimension and they
tend to be hyper successful and they
tend to be men.
So you see this in scientific
publishing,
for example.
So the median professor male publishes
as much as the median professor,
female,
but the vast majority of the,
of the high publishing people are males.
And that seems to be because there are a
small percentage of males who are very
static,
very focused,
very energetic,
and very much prone to put their career
first.
And part of the theory for why that is,
is that some men are that,
that the,
the,
um,
evolutionary and sexual tradeoff for men
with regards to high status is much
higher than it is for women.
So there's good documentation and I can
find these references to that.
The number of sexual partners or
opportunities that a man has in previous
year as tightly associated with the
socioeconomic status.
Whereas the number of partners or
opportunities for partnering that a
woman has is negatively correlated with
your status.
And that might be partly because high
status women who are looking for either
even higher status men priced themselves
out of the mating market and there's
actually pretty good of that as well.
So.
So you're fine,
you're fine with all of that.
The harm of Google was biases to achieve
a more equal gender and race
representation.
Google has created several
discriminatory practices programs,
mentoring in classes only for people
with a certain gender or race,
a high priority queue and special
treatment for diversity candidates
hiring practice,
which can effectively lower the bar for
diversity candidates by decreasing the
false negative rate.
Yeah,
that's a big problem.
Either have standards early,
don't.
The problem is is that if the standards
producing inequitable outcome,
then what happens is people criticize
the standards and that would be fine if,
if the standards board no relationship
to the job.
But the problem is,
is that if you have your hiring
practices set up halfway intelligently
and,
and it's never perfect,
you're actually hiring for attributes
that would make a job defectiveness much
more likely.
Yeah.
So how did you come across all this
information?
A part of it was through that diversity
summit
and just looking through all the stuff
that we have online or in through our
internal sites.
Yeah,
so you can do in a certain bit of
literature review.
Yeah.
These practices are based on false
assumptions generated by our biases and
can actually increase race and gender
tensions.
Yeah.
Well,
the whole unconscious bias thing is a
great example of that is like first of
all those tasks,
the implicit association tests are
nowhere near reliable or valid enough,
so nowhere near the quality necessary to
diagnose anyone as having a unconscious
bias.
Second,
second,
the data relating those so called
unconscious biases to actual behavior is
weak.
Third,
there was no evidence whatsoever that
anti unconscious bias training programs
have any positive effect whatsoever and
some that they have negative effect,
partly because people don't like to be
called racists and marched off to forest
reeducation training,
so suggestions.
Demoralized diversity.
Yeah,
that would be good.
And start to define it more
appropriately,
right?
Just start having a real conversation
about what proper hiring practices
should be,
which should be objective standards
universally applied without bias because
that's the best we can do that.
That's still going to introduce some non
equal outcomes,
but of course hiring practices are
designed to do that.
For example,
clearly designed to reward more
intelligent people
who is highly heritable.
That's actually a real problem.
Yeah,
definitely.
And we definitely set up hiring
practices to reward conscientious
people.
So,
um,
what are,
what,
what about banks need to negative
emotion?
It seems to me that screening for
stress,
which is a reasonable thing to do in
high stress jobs unless you want to put
the person in the position where they're
likely to collapse,
to be miserable.
I don't see any utility and not
Dr Peterson.
I had a question relating to that from
an employment standpoint.
Is there an Optima,
um,
sensitivity to stress that you've seen
from the most economically productive
employees?
By that I mean,
I feel like there's a middle ground
between people who are laid back versus
people who are,
um,
probably overstimulated by external
factors that make them self conscious.
And these people,
I think at least at the lower mid levels
of many companies actually have a little
bit more anxiety that powers their
ascension through the dominance
hierarchy.
Yeah.
Well it's a tricky issue because you're
probably the sort of negative emotion
that might be useful in motivating you
is probably more associated with
conscientiousness.
Then with neuroticism,
neuroticism seems to be pretty tightly
to anxiety and emotional pain,
frustration,
disappointment,
grief.
Those all sort of fit into those
categories.
Whereas the negative emotion perhaps
that's associated with conscientiousness
and industriousness in particular seems
to be more something like self contempt
and disgust and so conscientious people
are made uncomfortable by their lack of
productive effort,
but that doesn't seem to be associated
with trait neuroticism.
It's a different thing.
So that's partly why it's so necessary
to get the psychometrics.
Right,
right.
And to get the.
To get the measurement right.
So the best hiring,
the best hiring screeners are the big
five personality tests,
roughly speaking especially weighted
towards conscientiousness and for
complex jobs in general.
Cognitive ability test.
Although there is some question about
the legality of those in the current
political situation.
So
all alienating conservatives disposed
noninclusive and generally bad business
because conservatives tend to be higher
in conscientiousness,
which is required for much of the judge
and maintenance work characteristic of a
mature company.
Yes,
absolutely.
So
now here's what you suggest.
Confront those biases.
While you've done that.
We've seen how that went.
I would start by breaking down.
Google is scores by political
orientation and personality to give a
fuller picture and do our how our biases
are affecting our culture.
That's a fine idea.
Stop restricting programs and classes to
certain genders or races.
Yes.
Well obviously having open and honest
discussion about the costs and benefits
of our diversity programs.
Well,
I guess that's what we're trying to do
right now.
Discriminating just to increase the
representation of women in tech is
misguided and biased.
Is mandating increases for women's
representation in homeless work related
that violent as prisons and school
dropouts.
Yes.
It's the same thing and it's the same
issue as the bricklayer issue as well.
And what are you going to do?
You're going to chase the nurses out of
the women out of nursing and medicine
and psychology and social work.
And and university undergraduate
programs where they're radically
overrepresented.
So what about Jews?
You're going to get rid of them too.
They're overrepresented in most complex
occupations and Asians as well.
So are you only,
you're only going to do this in very
limited circumstances.
You're gonna.
Figure out some way to put a limit on
that or you seems very unlikely.
I almost wonder what the Adl is,
you know,
we'll be thinking six,
six months from now or 12 months from
now,
given the high number of,
you know,
at least in the United States,
I'm Ashkenazi Jews in leadership
positions at companies that are advocate
advocating for less of themselves are
less people who are in the bucket that
they're in.
Yeah.
Well as long as the discussion centers
on the overrepresentation of white men,
people seem to have no problem,
but you start to break that down a
little bit.
And because a Jewish white men are
particularly overrepresented as well,
I'm going to make an issue out of that.
Really.
We're going to do that.
So now the Asians are already having a
harder time getting into universities.
So that's well documented.
So.
And that that's a terrible thing,
partly because of the cost to the
individuals involved,
but also the cost to society because it
means that we're not taking the people
who are most competent and allowing them
to expand their education to the
greatest degree possible.
And because there aren't that smart
competent people are actually rather
rare and it's just society's advantage
to exploit the hell out of them and pay
them well for that.
But it's not like they're of no benefit
and everyone knows that when they try to
hire someone.
Competent de emphasize empathy.
Yes.
Empathy is a good
ethic for small family units and a
terrible ethic to run a company by.
It looks like conscientiousness is the
right ethic to run a company,
but I think conscientiousness,
we don't have good animal models for
conscientious will say.
But I think conscientiousness probably
evolved so that human beings could,
could operate in groups that were larger
than just kingsize,
you know,
because equity makes sense that a kitten
level.
Every mother wants her children to have
a good outcome in life and once
resources distributed equally between
them.
So it's not like it's something that
doesn't have a niche
micro prioritize intention,
our focus on microaggressions,
etc. And other unintentional
transgressions increases our
sensitivity.
You do A nice job of criticizing.
Now I read derald wing sue's book on
microaggression.
It's an appalling.
It's appalling load of tripe to put it
bluntly and I believe scott lilienfeld,
who's a very good psychologist,
has recently published a shredding the
the construct validity of the concept of
microaggression.
So it's a nonviolent construct right
from the bottom up.
It's purely ideological in nature and
it's also one of those constructs that
allows anyone who's offended to to
weaponize.
They're weaponized discourse around it.
So reconsider making unconscious
training bias training.
Mandatory for promotion committees.
Yeah.
That should be considered.
It should be stopped.
There's no scientific basis whatsoever
for proceeding with that operation.
so.
Great.
Well,
you know,
it's a pretty straightforward document
as far as I'm concerned and I've gone
through it with a fairly fine tooth comb
as a behavioral scientist and I would
like to state for the record that I
believe that what you said in there,
if not accurate,
was at least representative of the
current state of art,
a mall,
well trained psychometrically.
I'm informed psYchologists who are
experts in the field of individual
difference,
so congratulations
to pay such a price for it.
All right,
well thank you very much for the
conversation.
Oh,
one other question.
Why did you agree to talk to me?
I am a huge fan,
so I know that you went through similar
things being any influence on,
on this you're going to pay on.
Actually,
I'm not sorry.
I'd like to say I was sorry,
but I'm not actually really clean.
I,
I do think that you're going to be pay a
big price for this,
but that the net consequences will be
very positive and I'm.
I,
I think you did an excellent job on this
document.
I think you were very careful.
I think the fact that you're being
labeled with episodes and that you were
fired is absolutely reprehensible.
It's clear to me that you're just trying
to figure out what the hell is going on
and that you know you're not,
you're not any of the things that people
would like to think you are so that they
don't have to bloody well.
Think about what it is that you said it
did,
so congratulations to you that
courageous people are rare and you put
yourself on the line and I really
learned that in the last year.
So I would say keep your head up.
Assume that this is gonna work out.
I wouldn't hide from the press because
the press is actually,
you're the right person for the press to
be
something for you to use.
Know you're well spoken,
you're quiet,
you're,
you're convincing your rational.
Um,
you're obviously at least you come
across as a decent guy very,
very rapidly.
There's no reason I would say there's no
reason not to let people see who you are
because I think that would improve your
credibility and make your message even
more powerful.
So you think,
no doubt,
I mean you're,
you are,
have every right to defend your privacy,
you know,
but,
and that's fine,
but I don't think that you have any
reason to be afraid of depressed.
I would say a couple of things when
you're talking to the press,
don't apologize.
Don't tell people what you're not,
don't tell them that you're not going to
get a massage that's a technical error
and stick to your damn guns.
You kNow,
as,
as quIetly and forthright as you can.
And now you're going to come out on top
of this because you're,
you're on the side of the right as far
as I'm concerneD.